day as i as i speak to you i think we've
done about
four million people in this in this
country which is uh obviously
encouraging uh but just being here at
oxford biomedica and talking to the
people who are putting the vaccine
together here you can see how immensely
complex
it is and because it's absolutely got to
be
safe and it is safe it does take time
to to prepare so we're getting it out as
fast as as we can
uh four million done so far were now uh
i think uh have done um more than half
of the
uh of the over 80s uh almost half of the
or half of the people in care homes the
elderly elderly residents of
of care homes those groups remain a top
priority
don't forget though absolute priority
for us but it's right
as more vaccine comes on stream to get
it into the arms of the other
groups in the in the jcbi list the joint
committee and vaccination
and immunization list as well that's
what we're doing despite those
complications that you talk about the
fact it's difficult
are you guaranteeing that by september
everybody across the uk
adults will have been offered a vaccine
will that allow us
to basically get back to normal i
understand completely
the people want to get back to normal as
fast as we
possibly can it does depend nick on
things going well it depends on the
vaccination
program going well it depends on
there being no new variants that uh
that throw our plans out and that we
have to
uh to meditate against
and of course it depends on the the
everybody all of us
remembering that we're not out of the
woods yet you can see the pressure
that the nhs is under you can see the
the
the
i'm afraid still the the great uh number
of cases that we're seeing every day
we've got to maintain discipline
stop the spread of the virus by all the
basic ways that we know
not just washing your hands the rest of
it but staying at home
protecting the nhs stopping those trick
those chains of transmission
now in that crucial period as we as we
roll the vaccine out
in terms of how the vaccine is being
rolled out there are some questions over
some areas some parts of the uk not
being as quick as others are you
concerned
that there's a bit of a postcode lottery
at the moment well i think actually the
the whole of the uk is is going very
well
and overall the the pace of the
rollout is is very encouraging what
we're doing is making sure that
uh the armed services the army is on
standby everywhere it's embedded in the
whole
vaccine program uh across all of the
united kingdom
uh the armed services are helping
together with pharmacists
a great legion of volunteers and it's
it's we're going
as fast as we as we can but i but i
stress
uh we will do everything we can just get
back to your
your earlier point we'll do everything
we can obviously to
to open up but when we come to february
the 15th and the moment when we have to
take stock
of what we achieved that's the time to
look at
the uh whether the virus is
uh the extent of the of the infection
and the success
that we've had and it's only really then
that we can talk about
uh the way ahead and what steps we can
take uh to relax and
it will be i'm afraid i've got to warn
people it will be gradual you can't just
uh open up in a in a great uh
open sesame a great bang because uh
i'm afraid the situation is still pretty
precarious as people can tell
you did promise that things would be
relatively normal by the spring is that
still
the ambition of the government do you
still think that's possible yes i do
nick i do think that uh things will be
very different
by the spring and you'll have heard that
also from chris whittie
and patrick valance the chief medical
officer the chief scientific
advisor that doesn't mean that
we're not going to be living with the
consequences of
the arrival of the coronavirus pandemic
for for a while to come
uh the economic consequences and of
course the
the the threat to our health as well
we'll have to remain
vigilant about this i think for for a
long time you mentioned the economic
consequences being around for some time
one of the big questions that you need
to answer is whether you're going to
keep the
20 pound extra week you're giving to
people on universal credit can you tell
us
whether the government's going to
continue that beyond the end of march
well what we've said is that we'll put
our arms around the whole of the country
throughout the pandemic the countries
we've already done uh
i think 280 billion pounds worth of of
support
and we'll keep all measures obviously
under under constant review
we've got to get our country through the
the health crisis
uh i think that actually the uk is
capable of staging a very very
powerful economic recovery but we've got
to look after people
throughout the throughout the pandemic
that 20 pounds a week can be the
difference for some people between
feeding the family and not feeding the
family people want to know
if they're going to have that in a
couple of months time you know just give
them an answer on universal credit well
we're very proud of universal credit and
the introduction of universal credit and
you know i think there's
it's the policy of the opposition to
abolish uh universal credit altogether
uh which i don't think is a sensible way
forward you're the prime minister will
it be 25 extra
come april well as i say and we want to
support people
throughout the pandemic and what we
don't want to do is abolish universal
credit altogether this does mean a lot
to people's individual pockets though
they desperately want to know
if you're going to continue that can you
give us some clarity well
i think you've heard me say that we want
to support people throughout the
pandemic
we want to make sure that people don't
suffer as a result of the economic
consequences of the pandemic when you
look at what the government has done
to provide 280 billion pounds worth of
support the
the furlough scheme uh the
the bounce-back loans uh colossal
investment probably
uh more than the most other comparable
countries i don't think you could fault
uh the government for supporting people
we will continue to do that
just very quickly there are dozens of
hollyers holding up whitehall at the
moment because they want to know what
you meant
when you said that you were going to
support seafood exporters
through a tough period because of the
new brexit
red tape what are you going to do well
in so far as there are problems at the
moment
caused by uh teething problems people
not filling in the right forms or
misunderstandings
uh and when it's not people's fault of
course we're going to
compensate and and to help out and funds
have been
put in place to do that but be no doubt
nick that there are great opportunities
uh for fishermen across the whole of the
uk
to take advantage of the as i the
the spectacular marine wealth of the
united kingdom
in just five years time five and a half
years time we will have access
to all the fish in all of our coastal
waters and before then from now as i
talked to you today we have access to 25
more uh than we did
a month ago and that means that there is
scope for
uh fisher fishing communities fishers
across the uk
uh to take advantage of the increase in
quota and
what we're going to do is give people a
a helping hand and that's why we've set
up the 100 million
pound fund to help people with their
boats
to help the fish processing industry
in this country and and to help
rejuvenate
a historic and proud industry in the uk
and the government will support it
we think the opportunity is massive
what's your message for those exporters
who are losing money at the moment
because their food isn't getting to the
continent in time
i i sympathize very very much and i
i understand their frustrations and i
understand their concerns
obviously things have been exacerbated
by the kovid pandemic uh unfortunately
the demand in restaurants on the
continent for
uh for uk fish has not been what it was
before the pandemic
uh just because the restaurants have
been closed for
for so long and there that is one of the
the problems we're all trying to
to deal with unfortunately this is
driven in in large part
by the pandemic and we've put in place
all sorts of measures as i've
just been saying to help businesses
throughout the pandemic
what i'm also saying nick is that where
businesses through no fault of their own
have experienced bureaucratic delays
difficulties getting their goods through
whether there is a genuine
a willing uh buyer on the other side of
the
of the channel and they've had a problem
then there's a 23 million pound
uh compensation fund that we've set up
and we'll make sure that they get helped